what are you trying to get out of this
all this all this fake deep man stop
driving all the way over here for what
for what to show me my own lock screen I
know what she looks like I know who she
is she's my lock screen she's the love
of my life is the love of my life we're
just here to facilitate needs
to free it up
[Music]
what's good guys what's good girls as
you know
back with a banger we don't mess about
we go straight into the nitty gritty and
the question of the week was what's the
wildest excuse you've used to get out of
sleep in someone sleeping someone
sleeping with someone
and as per usual guys juicy woosy Boosie
you know how we do see the chin and them
things deser so oh boy yeah
I'm just gonna reel them off and we're
gonna have a good time
all right
um so what is it again what's the widest
excuse you've used uh to get out of
sleeping okay I'll sleep with someone
all right say less okay cool let's do it
I'm ready to laugh or not
we'll see we will see
get off me you're annoying
wow get off me you're annoying straight
straight in with a banger get off me
you're annoying that's one of them like
stop stop
stop stop get your tongue off my neck
get off
yeah
it's just so pink you're just so pain I
want to help myself
yeah can you feel that can you feel that
that's not my phone fam stop
get off get off me stink you stink
greasy head annoying oh your Sticky Lips
[Laughter]
I was so upset about fictional TV death
that I just can't get into it right now
I need time to grieve
wow
to be fat
if someone tried to slop me off like
after Ned Stark just got chops yeah I'm
chewing yeah literally what are you
doing did you not just see what happens
I'll be not watching the same thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah you should have hit
me up in episode two when the Twins were
doing doing the most
when these aren't we doing up incest
then come see me
but yeah nah after the Red Wedding get
out my face I need to process what I've
just seen so I wasn't expecting any of
this yeah any of this yeah yeah I told
her I need to pee I don't proceeded to
jump out the balcony what what spam like
like there was a gun to be said or
something yeah I've said I need to be to
get out of it like 11 times oh really
but that's because it was like
Scentsy
uh my tour was pulsating yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and I'm three Strokes in yeah
you're like and I'm like babes I'm so
sorry yeah I I Really Wanna like
you know I want to give you everything
but I can't I need to go toilet I have
to go toilet yeah she's like oh my days
what are you serious yeah I'm sorry
sorry
little spank I'll be back in the back
yeah I'll be splashing my face wake up
wake up you're just looking at your
mirror you're pointing at yourself yeah
yeah fix up bro fix up stop we can't
lose this after five minutes less than
we can't
a game only
this one this chick said none I just
reject him and go to sleep
no excuses no excuses I just reject him
just no no no rolls over not my girl I
promise you now that's not my girl
this chick said I'm struggling with my
sexuality maybe we should wait
I'm struggling with my sexuality I don't
even know if I'm attracted to your
gender yeah maybe we should just hold
off until I figure this out to figure
out what's going on inside of me first
and then I'll come back yeah because I
don't know if it's you
or just all of you yeah yeah yeah yeah
all of you man yeah I don't know if it's
you or you man yeah but satin's not it's
not patterning yeah yeah we've got a and
b and I'm not feeling C right now and a
potentially yeah yeah let's just
ease up hold on hold on WOW
in quotes you couldn't make me finish so
why would I
say why would I oh babe you know tonight
let's do a thing yeah I'm feeling a bit
you know I want to repeat a last time
you couldn't even make me finish so why
would I why would I would die
I just wanted that one who do you think
you're speaking to actual don't speak to
my life yeah like would you I I tried
that's your fault that's your fault we
erase it and you lost yeah bro you lost
the race G
we were both in this yeah
yeah before you're numb and heartless I
start getting deep
yeah when you attack me like that yeah
yeah why would I see with you you can't
even do me something it's just why would
I just why would I that's oh yeah
I'll wait till you finish yourself
okay say less
laughs
you're just not gonna like it
I just know I just I know you more than
anything you're not gonna like it is he
too short or something
I mean that doesn't matter to me but
told him I was on my period but really I
had thrush medication dripping out of me
[Laughter]
that's disgusting
that's disgusting let me wait till you
finish your soup bro you would have
ripping out with me
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's mad
wow that's mad wow yeah that's um mad
she was giving me head and she farted I
shouted I'm allergic and ran away
I'm assuming it was like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
he's chomping away and he just he
spreads cheek and he's just
Asylum of violenting and yeah he just
took a couple steps back and dipped
I'm allergic I'm allergic stop
s that's disgusting got his gums and ran
off man said I can't function without
Viagra that's a tough time that's a
tough obviously excuse but that's a
tough time thus
you don't even care what she says
you're so not on it you don't care where
she takes this information
do without what you will bro I can't I
can't function without Viagra
I'm I'm Keen to try Viagra I I am and
I'm not at the same time I want to know
if it obviously the difference it would
make is like you're just harder for a
lot longer right I'm assuming well I
think from what I've read
I don't know maybe someone can help me
out I'm pretty sure yeah I'm pretty sure
you're just solid but then like yeah I'm
pretty sure when you nut you're still
solid nah oh no actually I thought that
was the case okay that's why I was like
oh I can't wait to try it yeah but
apparently once you nut it's still the
same thing just happens so it's just
normal yeah but I think you're just
super hard
when when you're up when you're up yeah
when yeah when it's up when it's up
say less yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah so I don't know maybe a little
Cialis
um I'm intrigued I'm intrigued I mean I
don't think my heart can take it so
that's the thing I'd that's like a
foreign body that's a real foreign body
do you know what I mean like I don't
know about different things yeah it
sounds terrifying it sounds terrifying
oh
he was eating me out and it was so bad
that I told him never mind let's hug
instead and left ASAP
never mind
never mind not even stop I can't do this
I don't like it yeah yeah never mind
wow wow I couldn't hear that James I
promise you I can hear that never could
I never mind what do you mean never mind
yeah yeah wow never mind mind honestly
flakes just honestly never mind hug me
that's what matters at this moment
that's what matters more to me that's I
can feel something with you hugging me
yeah I could feel something really hug
me yeah everything else is just nah nah
never mind never you mind so that's not
even like she's not even does she say
stop eating me out it was just like
we're not sleeping together because
you're just useless useless the hug is
probably the bare minimum I'm gonna get
right now the most enjoyment I'm gonna
get from him is the hug that's a muscle
feeling that's impossible it's
impossible it's impossible mad
I've got chronic manhood pains when in
reality I'm not at five minutes before
she woke up
[Music]
Rags just a nose breathing traps
toes cold
yeah just held it
oh yeah and then you look back to see
the other week yeah yeah and then just
like right click just Dash a tissue on
the floor
and then just
[Applause]
back up
nah and then she woke up and said Daddy
no give me that his heart would have
skipped oh Rago because what's the
excuse what's the actual excuse dad give
me that I'll be terrified yeah
a sting I want to be fresh for you I'll
be in there shake it oh shake it out I
would lock it for 20 minutes she'll make
breakfast or something yeah
I'll be yeah I'll be sat on the toilet
staring at the door shower burst on
thinking get bored get bored get bored
get bored what am I gonna do oh that's
hilarious oh this horrible that is that
is hey just quick reminder what's the
widest excuse you've used to get out of
sleeping with someone I took his phone
and showed him the lock screen of his
girlfriend
it's like isn't that your gal
I swear that's your girl
what's that Disney World School no oh my
God
she got Juiced up oh well oh well oh
well
my girl laughs that's how the
transaction was right literally I
started back and forth would go now
my girl she got Juiced up oh wow
[Music]
your girl
you should have said that before I was
in here with you you should have said
that was before I was on you knew what
we were on we're in the same Dunya why
are we doing this yeah what are you
trying to get out of this all this all
this fake deep man stop driving all the
way over here for what for what to show
me my own lock screen I know what she
looks like I know who she is she's my
lock screen she's the love of my life is
the love of my life we're just here to
facilitate needs so free up
what are we talking about here
facilitate needs bro that's the love of
my life bro shut up
don't even speak on her facts don't even
mention her name put my phone down
are we skinning up or not let me know so
I can delete you from my contacts yeah
because I'm going straight home to her
after this whether we not or Not facts
Oh my days the audacity
jeez
all right fake to panic attack because
he smelled so bad I blocked him before I
left his front door
wow before I left his front door yeah
girls I've got balls of steel I remember
I was talking to a check once um she
told me she she was seeing a bread or I
don't know if it was like frequently or
something but he came round I think it
was either like somewhat too demanding
or something but he just wasn't oh this
was it this was it this was it this was
it she was trying to be sexy instead his
phone was ringing she wanted to answer
it while he was while he was um not
while she was on top of him on like a
sex scene like I'll call me back call
him later I'll call him later but the
the hold on let me let me let me let me
learn
but the um the person that called was
saved as a man's name but it was his
missus
Raymond yeah Raymond
yeah and then
and obviously grabbed the phone and then
obviously altercation altercation
whatever she got off and did her thing
or whatever and as he was about to leave
she said as he was about as he was
putting on his shoes he buckled
say of course he did barcode and he said
before he left the yard he blood she
blocked him on everything on absolutely
everything yeah Rags because he lost
yeah and that's like Yeah the more all
I'm hearing is don't be answering Man's
phone [ __ ] you that's all I'm hearing so
that that could never I would
my sex drive will go completely don't
reach for my phone because I will
probably put you in a figure form yeah
you can reach it
don't reach for my phone
it's just not on where did you learn
that term figure four wrestling bro oh
yeah
I'll put her in a figure four
yeah Rags Pro oh yeah get off my phone
reach for my stuff trying to be sexy
like call him later
even if it was you yeah don't answer my
phone Rago just do not answer my phone
that literally if it was if it was you
bro because I'm waiting for a big man
who was that Rags bro like honestly one
thing in it I'll tell you why is she
answering your phone I don't know
I don't even want to discuss I don't
want to talk about it honestly let's
move on jeez yeah yeah yeah look
um she said I love you right before so I
told my mom to call me I yell at me so I
could leave
Oh my days found this one it slipped out
while she was on top and I missed the
re-entry I was in pain and told her I
needed to go and study
hahaha
bro mystery entry
bend it quick bro it's gonna bend it
quick
your tool will snap out of it it will
snap out of it
all of this I mean when I was young I
missed a re-entry yeah on a back shot
thing hurt both of us hurt both of us it
got that like that middle yeah yeah yeah
the middle team yeah yeah yeah yeah
tompped it oh because I was on a bat
yeah and then it just a little bit too
much and I went straight back in without
realizing it just it yeah yeah and I was
like yo and she was like
and then she tried she tried to carry on
carry on camera this is she trying to
carry on camera fam I was like oh I was
like you sure she was like shut up just
carry on like you're ruining the move
yeah yeah put it in fam as I signed in
she was shaking
as I was putting it back issue shaking I
said no no no no no no stop this I found
two Tremors I was like stop stop stop
what are we actually doing
foreign
agony
I was like bro why are we doing it we'll
pick this back up tomorrow what's going
on that's hilarious that's hilarious oh
that's that's so unsexy it's just not
sexy at all Shake it jeez
there was no excuse she was a catfish I
kissed my teeth closed the door and put
the latch on
literally front door thing you know open
up just like are you sure are you you're
looking at your family you look at her
and you look at your phone again
big man thing I didn't order Pizzeria
Express I didn't order pizza expenses I
don't know why what you are but this is
wrong transaction yeah fam I'll be
waiting for her to like preach like our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
yeah yeah yeah because clearly you're at
the wrong door yeah have you heard the
news that's
how I opened the door hello have you
heard the news if I'm not hearing that
yeah what's going on you might never be
like James no no no no no no no no
literally yeah Rags latch on
man said I'ma make you a single mother
if you keep this up
what I'm gonna make you a single mother
if you keep this up
wow
that's a threat there's very few things
men can threaten women with that is one
and that is wholesome leak one
wow she already think a whole yeah yeah
yeah 100 that's hilarious I told her my
toes hurt she called me a liar got up
and left
laughs
my toes hurt you're such a liar you're a
liar I'm if I'm so hideous to you I just
say so to me just tell me more you do it
oh you're a liar left you're a liger
I told him I braid my coochie hair in a
ponytail I haven't seen him since of
course don't even joke about stuff like
that
that's made me feel sick
that's disgusting
yeah
I told a girl we can only kiss because
I've got a bunch of ingrown hairs down
there and it ain't cute
this is a brat yuck
man's just got pipe and pus and that's
it yuck
pipe and bumpy pops that's disgusting
that is disgusting thank you what's he
doing is he shaving
foreign
[Laughter]
I told him I barked when I'm having
orgasms he threw me off my own bed and
left
oh women play too much oh barked you
know on some speeding
I couldn't well yeah to be fair I
wouldn't bother me you bark when you
what orgasm minor
man so no barking will be had today is
what you're saying that's fine
yeah
yeah I don't bark so there will be no
barking today
hilarious oh that was funny bro well
played I'm sweating already all right
guys welcome back welcome back to the
second best podcast on planet Earth and
some would say Beyond
um happy to have you happy Monday as
always guys if you do want a little bit
more of the juice a little bit more of
the squeeze head on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs for three
plus years of uncensored content plus an
extra episode every Thursday and an
official indoctrination into the cult
babies we are your cult daddies J Money
and firelord flags and we look after you
over there okay it's gonna cost you a
measly humble three pound a month a day
you need to run the P to sng and join
the rest of the cult babies guys we're a
big uh we're a big deal now we're not
playing around we are a big deal like
you guys were clowning us and doubting
us for Years bro we're here
um as always guys please subscribe to
the channel
um but Italians comes out I think we
would have passed 500K
uh let's have a look see yeah hopefully
hopefully hopefully hopefully hopefully
um so yeah hopefully by the time this
comes up we would have passed 500 000
subscribers and that will be Sensational
um or maybe we might be on the edge I'm
thinking now that's only a few days this
comes out in a couple days
yeah I've got faith in you man
I've got a favorite you man yeah for
future casting yeah we've got faith guys
so anyway
as always guys um subscribe to the
channel like the video if you like the
video chirps a thing in the comments and
lastly guys if you are listening on any
of our audio platforms please like
follow leave a nice review five stars is
preferable we've got a lot of five stars
but we appreciate every single one you
have no idea what it means for the
growth of the channel uh for the growth
of the show and uh for the growth of our
wallets
um and guys without any further Ado I'm
going to hand you over to my boy file of
wigs he has some stuff to get off his
chest in the sport of football yeah so
let's get into it
um as you all know my beloved United
um we had a rocky start to the season
but I feel like we are slowly becoming
the team Eric tanhaag wants us to be
right bet so um let's get into it okay
so post woke up post how many matches
have we had so
when this comes out we would have had
two Premier League games and an FA Cup
games an FA Cup game is tomorrow which
is Friday but you know what I'm saying
um but we have won we've won both of our
games and
um for the Prem games of the Prem games
yeah yeah and um
our
oh no no we've had four teller we've had
four games post World Cup so we had a
cup game
um which we beat Burnley two nil we had
uh Premier League game uh against Forest
which we beat them free now uh Wolves
game away one nil and Bournemouth which
is just played frino let's go had four
clean sheets
um since the return of the post World
Cup let's go Ashford has been born I've
heard
that's all I've heard yeah he's back
he's back he's basically back he's
earning his paper checkbook yeah
whatever he wants yeah basically
whatever you want yeah stay less still
in bits like we've got the nice skeleton
of our of our um Squad now
um
lisandro's back lisandra Martinez he won
the World Cup of Argentina he's back in
the squad now but it's it's mad because
our defense is strong we've got Varan
back in the middle of ran back in uh
defense we've got Casimir just doing
bits in the Midfield once we've got
rashford up front just cleaning up for
everyone so our Squad now is looking
very very good we've lost one game in
16. oh
comps not included with like we had
United had two friendly I think almost
everyone had two friendlies during the
World Cup season so all the people that
didn't actually travel yeah
yeah four things yeah no one cares about
it yeah not National level but it's fine
exactly but bar those games we've lost
one game out of 16. okay and that game
that we lost was against
um Aston Villa and we lost 3-1 which is
annoying yeah rem's like REM is a
villafan
um so unai Emery he was the old Arsenal
manager and old Sevilla manager is it
Seville or Villarreal
um he is now managing Aston Villa and
their first game was against United and
lost that game and this was I think this
was pre this was pre-World cup we lost
that game of like damn and he you could
tell by his tactics that oh he's going
to do something with Villa this season
it was good to see
but we then play them in a cup that same
week
um but we play them at home and we beat
them 4-2 which was good
um and what else was going to say so
remember when we lost against
C63 yes so our next Premier League game
as you can see by the time this comes I
think it'll be that this weekend okay
home or away we play at home and I we
play City at home and then I think the
week after we play Arsenal so our
back-to-back games are looking a bit
tantalizing yeah but I feel like this is
the best time to play them yeah yeah yes
we are because yeah cool we are on form
and I as long as our team stays fit it's
not the rashford stays fit yeah that's a
mirror stays fit like the the core
skeleton including David de Gea I just
don't see us
I don't see us either lose I don't see
us losing to see okay I just know it's
going to be a goal Fest but I hope we
just do what we do everything hard proud
because we've got absolutely tucked in
last time and I still don't see um
Arsenal beating us
um at their ground we place we play
Arsenal away and I I don't see them
being us but hopefully when this comes
out you guys would know and see that
yeah United are united on up and I'm
gonna premise this now
think
I think will come second or third this
season so yeah I've got that much faith
in the team as long as they stay fit
yeah as long as everyone stays fit touch
would and hopefully we sign a striker
this month because this is where in um
transfer window element Hall of January
transfer window we need another Striker
martial isn't really banging in Gaza as
I expected him to he's very inconsistent
at the moment
um Anthony is not doing much on the um
on the wings
even though when he came he was scoring
he scored maybe like four in six games
Okay
um but I was at the beginning of season
he's not really scored since then maybe
you're talking about yeah yeah he scored
against C yet um yeah he scored against
Arsenal as well so it's um we just need
another Force like we need another
fearing person in our Squad and that
would hopefully take us to the next
level all right tell us and Jaden Sancho
I know I'm rambling Now by Jaden Sancho
he he's on like a
he's abroad he's abroad like gearing
himself up Eric tanghai said before
World Cup you need to train yeah I don't
know why I don't know what the
conversation was okay he's not been in a
squad he's he's been I think he's been
somewhere somewhere in Dubai or
something like that or somewhere hot
anyway just trying altitude training you
just need to get better get back to the
form you're at oh yeah Dortmund that's
the man we want yeah yeah yeah and then
we'll see because if Jade and Santa
comes back and pulls and pulls his
weight I'm hoping it will add him enough
fear and vigor into the team as well it
gives us options you know you can't just
keep going down one side bro I would
love I don't know why I would love it
but like there's something so sexy about
like
um being like I don't know like the
whole like Dragon Ball Z Time Capsule
style of like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah just go away and
like come back man up man up yeah come
back on a Shippuden thing yeah Jeremy
yes yes come back with some Sage juice
or science yes yes bro because you've
got potential bro dude just go away and
come back and then like yeah just
dedicating your life to that and be like
I'm gonna come back a new man and then
you step on and everyone could just feel
that net that all right oozing off and
just give them like that shadow step and
they're like wow
you've been running in sand just for
time say less say less welcome back yeah
welcome back welcome back yeah I love
that [ __ ] that Rocky style take you to
the gutter like punching [ __ ] pork
carcasses
yeah
yeah yeah they come back a new man but
I'm I'm hoping sanjo comes back to
demand that he was at Breezy durman and
the rest of the reason why we signed him
and stuff so yeah we will see we will
see but we have I have a lot of faith in
our team this season because we are we
are playing very good football Peng
posts
um they're like the little bump we were
going through like the beginning of the
Season very well so yeah um cool right
I've got
um a little thing to talk about I know
they usually do like our gym catch-ups
and like Fitness catch-ups on patreon
but um I need to get off my chest now
okay right so firstly
ah
your boys don't terrible this week okay
terrible gym or nutritional both okay
the one thing that I think has ruined it
for me has been
um the one thing I think I've ruined it
for me is but I've been because I've
been really busy the last two weeks okay
and for the last two weeks I've been
training in the evening Christmas New
Year period yeah it's impossible to
train in the evening for me I need that
so the best times I train
or the the times I felt best with my
training and my health and stuff is
where I like get a good night's sleep I
wake up
um and I have a pre-workout I get I wake
up have a shower get straight into my
gym kit I have a pre-workout on an empty
stomach okay go to the gym and I [ __ ]
train hard on an empty stomach Daddy
on a fast ending
and then I train like a madman yeah and
I come I want to come out it worked
penly in summer pengally in summer and
you come out all you want is water and
fresh salad or something yeah yeah yeah
you just want like hell yeah you want
Health bro so that was working for me in
summer and I was doing really really
well the last few weeks I've been
training the evening
um and bro your whole day is a slog yep
like the caffeine that late in the day
foxes your sleep every day you're waking
up tired and by the time there's not
enough caffeine in the world to give you
the energy to train harder like eight
o'clock at night nine o'clock at night
and then when I'm doing it and because
it's late and I just want to get out of
there I'm skipping cardio I was doing
really well on cardio I've been skipping
it the last two sessions I've skipped it
okay and these whole like without
training plan these two second holds
come on man I'm just doing it I'm just
I'm not good
um so this week's been really bad for me
and nutrition wise so because I canceled
my meals you said yeah yeah yeah and
they were late coming in so I didn't get
them I haven't had a meal since the last
delivery they did was like the 18th of
December and I only just got my last
delivery two days ago did you um write a
complaint about the week they missed oh
hell yeah no no actually to be fair no I
didn't I was in the midst of writing to
complaint and I checked my account and I
was actually wrong I spoke out of turn
they didn't charge me okay for the week
that didn't come okay but they said that
they did they definitely emailed me
saying that they did okay but they
didn't actually do it I checked my bank
and I checked their the subscription
thing and they didn't charge me for okay
cool um but yeah obviously I went a week
without it over Christmas they've come
back I didn't get it till the third
which again it's not their fault because
we have bank holidays and stuff but so
I've just gone like two weeks without
like meal prep which means my diet's
been off
um I've now had my meal prep uh my last
because I canceled my subscription with
them because I'm not feeling their food
my last ones came because I paid for it
um and [ __ ] around with the food in
there as well there's been a few
substitutions I didn't ask for again
again but one of the this time they've
thrown in a mastermind Curry and daddy
likes a master mankari so I wasn't too
angry at that but principally I was yes
principally I was angry at it but I was
like you're lucky I like myself that's
pain yeah yeah and I strand that one
cracked her open and scrammed it
and I was like that was actually Bank
um but anyway I'm gonna look for a new
one this week yeah quick break guys want
to miss you a Happy New Year from our
friends over at manscaped and the ball
has officially dropped but that doesn't
mean you have to drop the ball on your
you guessed it Bulls in 2023 whether you
had a new year laughs
whether you had a New Year's kiss or not
the leaders in below the waist grouping
have you covered for your much needed
resolution bringing sexy back we're
bringing sexy back guys okay this is
what 2023 said we're bringing sexy back
let's go you need to join the seven
million man worldwide who trust my
escaped with our exclusive offer all you
need to do is head on over to
manscape.com and use the code s n g
Sierra November golf for 20 piss off 20
off and free shipping worldwide let's
have a toast for the new year new you
and a new you with and a new year and a
new and a new you with no pubes I got
there in the end guys
there's a moth in here
let's get back to the show
and um yeah man so
that's been awful but two new additions
to my lifestyle have happened that I've
taken my health and wealth to another
level okay I'm listening daddy's been
doing ice baths in the morning yes we've
got to talk about this yes right yes yes
so I bought a cold plunge pool like
a time ago I was on a hype I was
listening to podcasts and then telling
me [ __ ] yeah Andrew huberman got in my
head and I'm feeling gas gas gas so I'm
like bet I'm buying one spoke to Lewis
I buy it because he's in his like motto
for life is cold shower [ __ ] he was
gives himself a cold shower and all that
stuff okay so I was like bro I'm taking
this cold shower [ __ ] to the next level
I'm getting myself a cold plunge pool
I'm gonna do ice baths in the morning
and he laughed and said no you won't you
can't even get in a cold shower or
basically he didn't say this but was
white red yeah yeah you're a [ __ ] and
there's no I'll bet my mortgage that you
ain't getting on my pool in the morning
and you're a liar you're a liar and a
joke yeah yeah and you don't deserve
love what happens or anything
is hilarious it's beyond me yeah and
it's there's a time limit on it and it's
coming because you're pathetic that's
all I read when really you probably just
swear down yeah
[Music]
good luck with that yeah um but anyway
so I bought it yeah sat in the Box for
weeks I just kept forgetting about it
and then the other day I was like no no
no I'm doing this so
took it outside filled it up in the
garden first day I just did water I'm
throwing ice in there just did cold
water I ain't putting ice in there so
I've done it twice so far I've skipped
the last couple days
um because you have a hose in your
garden
uh well this one's low enough that I
could just do it to the tap that was on
the wall but I need it if I get a bigger
one which I will I'm gonna have to get a
hose okay
um but anyway filled it up
and then woke up in the morning scared
scared
I was like am I Really Gonna Do This am
I really really gonna do this yeah um
and I was like I bet so I thought okay
because so the optimal time I think
you're supposed to do it's like three
minutes okay so I was like I'm gonna do
one minute on the first day two minutes
on the second day and then the third
time I'm gonna do it three minutes and
then just keep going from there so first
day comes hype myself up come on come on
come on come on come on go out there get
in obviously freezing yeah yeah yeah and
um but I'm I'm at up I did the one
minute okay did the one minute okay and
I was like bet alarm went off got out
and I was like oh how was your breathing
the breathing wasn't too bad you know
what it is I realized the breathing when
you first get in you're like yeah yeah
but literally once you sink into it your
breathing is fine and you can just sit
there I realized that the breathing
is when you put cold shower on your
breathe is murked and I think it's the
like constant like
um it's the motion of the water that
messes with your breathing because on
day two so this is day two so I did day
one and I was like I'm a man yeah I'm a
man yeah
my endorphins levels are up I'm feeling
good you get in the shower and like your
Skin's tingling for like an hour
afterwards in a warm nice way and you're
like bet I've set the day off nicely
okay cool I'm glad I did that tomorrow
we're doing two minutes and obviously I
left it overnight
I left out there overnights when I got
in the next day it was very cold and the
next day took me about 40 minutes to
work myself up to get in there because
14 minutes it was pissing down with rain
so picture this is pissing down with
rain it's windy you can hear the Wind
Through the Windows and stuff no I stood
at my back door in my towel just staring
at it 40 minutes no staring at the top
thinking I don't think I can do this I
promise I would have walked away I
promise you but I didn't leave the back
door because I thought James because
it's raining out there as soon as you
get out there you're going to get in
that pool because if it was a sunshiny
day if I'm not in the mood I could get
out there enjoy busting in the side and
just go back inside and be like no why
would I do it to myself so like I'm
looking I'm thinking come on you can do
this you can do this but then this is
the this is where the mental strength
comes in okay on day one I kept thinking
think how good you're going to feel
after I think how amazing this is going
to be after all this after after after
and then like the sense of like
accountability that you're going to feel
the sense of achievement you're going to
feel day two comes around now and it's
raining and it's windy all of a sudden
your brain's like yeah but what is
achievement real yeah what's that all
about yeah when we're getting down to
Brass tags yeah what's the sense of
achievement I'm happy now yeah yeah I'm
happy right now it's warm in here and
it's calm like we feel achievement with
what we've accomplished in our life
four Halls yeah I've got four yeah I've
got a roof over our head we've achieved
enough yeah yeah we don't need this the
bank is Big yeah yeah everything in life
is blessed you don't need to feel any
more sense of achievement just stay
inside yeah 40 minutes bro I was like
Wow and then I was like I have to do
this
and then I started thinking about
triggers that really work for me okay
which is like questioning my manhood
okay so as long as if as soon as I'm
like well if you don't do it you're
actually not even a man like you're such
a [ __ ] like everything Lewis you
thought Lewis said actually is true it's
true yeah you are a [ __ ] you can't even
get out there second day in a row no I
was like say this Dash my towel went out
there in my boxes yeah
so well this is a good thing because it
was raining yeah exactly like I said
as soon as you're out there in the piss
and rain in your boxes yeah
the least of your troubles is getting in
this pool facts
I'm out in my boxes in the pouring rain
in England yeah what is this literally
what is life and the wind is gargling
and I was like all right back get in
yeah got in sat in it it was way colder
than the day before that's what my
briefing was like oh yeah yeah so I got
in and I'm like
now this is where I got tacky okay
because you're like oh and as soon as
you calm yourself down the wind goes
Shrum and then you're like and then you
can't focus anymore it was a test of
will yeah and obviously the rain is
still the rain is still pouring on you
and you're like
left my phone inside so I couldn't tell
the timer I was in there no word of a
lie four and a half hours
and then the timer went off
clearly my phone died someone broke into
my house put the charger on
and then until gauges to turn back on
and then it remembered that I'd set a
two minute timer and then four and a
half hours later the timer went off oh
mad it was the longest two minutes of my
life oh my goodness bro
I was like this is impossible someone's
turned off my timer bro yeah yeah yeah
yeah I've been in it for hours and then
uh but then after that one you get out
okay I went straight upstairs to my
shower there was a line of red where
that was wow here down completely red
wow and it's not easy to turn brown skin
red yeah completely red from here it was
cold in there it's hypothermia yeah
I was like Wow but then I felt great
afterwards so when you sh when you go
back upstairs a shower do you use hot or
cold hot okay okay so to balance house
yeah yeah there's no way I'm getting in
the cold thing to go in a cold shower
yeah I'll kill myself okay okay yeah I'd
intentionally just like slip and then
just
it's essentially
oh it's actually just pour shower gel on
the on the floor and just slip crack my
skull open I'm not doing that bro
um so yeah cold cold tub into a hot
shower yeah you feel amazing after yeah
you feel amazing after okay I missed day
three and day four so day three
yesterday I had a dentist appointment
early don't know why I agreed to it so
early early that also was a nightmare
um so I just didn't do it yesterday
because I thought I haven't got time to
like be prancing around I haven't got
this 40 minute yeah yeah window work up
time yes I was like let's just go Dennis
when Dennis uh and then today
obviously you know I was busy this
morning and then I had came straight
here so I didn't do it today either but
I'm definitely doing it tomorrow okay um
cool cool but it's uh if I can make it
consistently and do it for the rest of
this month yeah I'm gonna buy myself a
proper one with the one you have now
does it have like a temperature gauge so
you know what no it's just a container
for water I've got a cheap it cost me
like 50 Quid a cheap container for water
is it is it one of them ones where you
can sit in or you have to get and then
you're standing up or like you're like
like this so it's like um you have to
like proper like squat down into it to
sit in it it's not very big at all okay
okay it's like imagine this chair from
like it's probably yeah like the
circumference of my knees round to the
back of this chair okay it's small and
then once you sit in it it's like here
okay I'm with you it's not nice it's not
nice but the the proper ones that have
temperature and like control like can
keep it like Ice level they're like 10
bags oh they're expensive okay and
there's even Joe Rogan uses a crazier
one that keeps the water slightly in
motion so you can't that comfortable
feeling of like Stillness doesn't let
you have it it just keeps the cold water
moving around you don't know how he does
it I don't know how he does it wow yeah
he must he's alert though afterwards he
says it's amazing he did a video the
other day that helped me get in because
he did it because he talks about on a
show all the time like yeah I've been
getting it every day it's grim and you
hear him say it's Grim but you're like I
don't think you really think it's Grim
yeah because you just keep doing it
you're doing it every day he did a
Instagram uh post the other day of him
outside in his rope outside in his rope
and he's like I don't want to do this
I don't want to do this yeah he said
this is the worst part of my [ __ ] day
I hate it Rogue comes off gets in it and
he just sat there like staring at the
thing I was like that's a man that's
actually a man like he would kill
something with his bare hands he's a man
yeah he is to be fair so I want to be
that man okay say less so I'm gonna keep
getting in these ice bars I'm gonna get
colder and colder get a bucket of ice
and keep stop putting in how does it um
how does it affect the rest of your day
well here's the thing I thought there's
no real like wow I'm buzzing there's not
that's what I expected but maybe it's
just not cold enough and maybe I'm just
not in it long enough okay it's still
baby steps but
um
after you obviously you get that warm
tingly feeling and you're like this is
nice
but I have realized it could be Placebo
I have realized that things that would
typically annoy me
things that would typically annoy me
haven't been annoying me things I
typically normally haven't been annoying
me just like you're very like calm
nothing's just that it's not that deep
okay no matter what nothing's that deep
and there have been some things that
have annoyed me okay nothing's that deep
okay um
keep going keep getting it colder
because that's real hardship hey I think
if nothing else it just puts it in
perspective of like nothing's that deep
Bro yeah you got in a freezing cold tub
this morning yeah okay so I'm gonna keep
doing it and I like that mindset second
thing okay I bought so the other week
um
when we were drinking
in my hotel they had this like hangover
kit okay I don't know why but they just
had it complementary my room and it came
with like those like uh you know there's
like little things that you put under
your eyes yeah the the midge mask yeah
they call it midi Masters yeah yeah yeah
um
shouts to my Jammer yeah
I don't think it was her brand but
shouts of my job
um and then they also had these
hydration tablets okay hydrogen tablets
yeah yeah so it's like a dissolvable
thing you put it in the water fizzes up
and then you back it and it's got all
like the salts and minerals and [ __ ]
that you need to stay hydrated I was
like gang so I thought I'd take it in
the morning but what I ended up doing it
was taking it like two o'clock in the
morning before I went to bed okay
I woke up in Newman field
I'm not gonna play with you apart from
the lack of sleep I was a bit tired yeah
in terms of hangovers okay zilch really
I had nothing I was fine okay I was fine
okay and I again could be an accident
yeah yeah but I was like say swear okay
so obviously
me being me I got obsessed started doing
research on hydration hydration tablets
and I bought I spent 40 quid on a pack
of hydration salt like sacheting okay
company called liquid IV yeah I heard
about them before because uh a couple of
podcasts I listened to they used to
promote on there okay
um and I was like bet liquid IV yeah
yeah so it comes in a sachet okay I've
got watermelon flavor banging yeah
banging it tastes like drinking seawater
though it's very salty
but it's like well it's not not that
deeper you have to have enough water
let's just say that okay okay and I've
been having that the last few days and
I'm gonna try I've been having it the
last two mornings but then I might mix
up it's made me feel okay
um nothing special but it's made me feel
okay what I'm gonna do though
um maybe no I've already had it maybe
tomorrow night I might have it before
bed before bed and see how it got yeah
yeah see how it makes me feel when I
wake up okay because I always feel
groggy when I wake up okay if it helps
me if it helps me with that every night
every night yeah every night without
fail without fail so yeah yeah those are
the two things I've implemented so next
week Daddy's going back to train in the
morning on an empty stomach coming back
eating like a king I'm gonna have my
liquid IV and my ice baths in the
morning so it'll be routine this is my
routine I'm saying it to the 10 billion
people that listen to the show yep every
morning every morning next week yeah I'm
here bro I'm here I'm locked your boy's
waking up yeah he's calling his skin off
in this ice bath for three minutes like
a man would yeah he's then they're going
to go upstairs have a steamy shower
not watch a second upon yep yep yep yep
which I haven't done
I came close to the other day though
that's the address for another story
came close the other day anyway I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna watch any blue
movies yeah yeah yeah I spark hot shower
no blue movies in the morning or evening
yeah
then gym pre-workout I bought a new
pre-workout as well as banging okay
pre-workout with ice lots of water more
hydration drive straight to the gym as
fast as I can yeah work out like a man
yeah do all the isometric contractions
yeah yeah yeah all those eccentric three
second [ __ ] things he's asking us to
do I'm gonna do all of that yeah cardio
half an hour every time come home
sweating eat like a man chicken rice
beef
crap yeah
then shower again
work make money like a man
that liquid IV before bed and that's the
day sleep like a king's the day parents
that's the day pattern maybe some skin
on skin in there if I've got time
slide in somewhere in between making
money
making money and building muscle you're
in there with skin or skin somewhere
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay say
less that's what I'm on say less I have
to do it for a whole week I have to all
right we'll we'll reconvene this
conversation next week damn right we
will all right say let's be you're damn
right we will say less I'm intrigued to
know I'm intrigued to see if it changes
your mood and your outlook when you come
in here next time oh yeah I'm hoping
that I literally like don't even bother
opening the door I hope I like run
through the wall next to the door
and just say what is it yeah all right
bet
um cool right massive change of topic
okay I've got a question for you okay
gang I like when we have questions for
me
um
in a scenario
where I have
very accidentally committed a heinous
crime in a communist country
like like example a heinous crime yeah
uh like I don't know let's say I
accidentally run over like
a prince of Dubai or something okay but
is it a real man accident yeah you're in
the car had nothing to do he basically
jumped in front of the car okay and I'm
like raw and you're like raw James hey
yeah do you know who that was yeah we
could be chopped into pieces by tomorrow
yeah yes yes yes yes yes yes so they
catch on CCTV they know you have nothing
to to do with it okay and you say James
you need to run and I tell you where I'm
going and I just go there you might I
drop you off at the back of the
apartment yeah and you're like bet run
away
you're telling me to run away yeah
they pick you up who's they 5-0 yeah
just their man in it yeah
that man
yeah yeah they take you to a cave
somewhere oh wow they sit you down light
in your face yeah how many fingers are
you gonna lose before you wrap me out
fingers yeah oh
so they put your hand flat on a table
here and say where is he okay so now I'm
the interrogate I'm the interrogator
yeah okay yeah your fans out cool cool
cool cool I've got pliers yeah here's
ready yeah yeah yeah yeah where is he
with that pressure yeah I'm squealing
that pressure I'm squealing that they
could have I promise you they couldn't
even rip off my nail they couldn't rip
off my fingernail I would scream brother
foreign
bro you're saying what are you saying to
me
I don't know they've picked you up I
don't know anything oh I left my phone
in the seat so they can't track me
unaware I'm unaware of the whole thing
okay okay okay so hands out this is the
pressure where is he that's a lot of
problems pliers players where is your
boy and when we find him his head's
coming straight off no stop all of that
and you're saying he's not his fault bro
it's nice for you saw the cameras I said
I'll just say it wasn't him we saw we've
got it and they've got it on the TV on
repeat it's me and they're just playing
the spread and you can see my face in
The Tingler
you see my face is a tick like I look
directly in the camera
images of the freeze frame everything I
look directly at the camera scared
scared
and and the directly the camera scared I
look and I spin off and they cut they've
got the whole thing yeah on the TV right
there okay quite let me let me digress
into this scene
is
is it just one man with pliers in the
room how many men are there let's let's
fully dive into okay if you need the
details yeah there's about eight man in
there oh God so we've got
the we've got the muscle so we've got
the commander who's like he's got like a
horrible little yeah Dash team a warrior
stash and like he's just a waste man yep
hands behind his back yeah yeah he's
skinny and he's just he loves torturing
man he doesn't do the torturing yeah
yeah he commands people to do torturing
yeah he's got him in there he's the one
asking the questions
we've got one skin Ed who's got next
man's blood still on his hands like you
know when you try he tried to wash it
off with the soap yeah so he's got like
a weird Faded Line around here yeah so
here down is clean but he's just got a
weird bloody line right here he just he
just washed his hands from doing this a
minute ago she's warmed up yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's desensitized yeah he's
just literally [ __ ] yeah yeah and
then we've got about three men guarding
the door Wham yeah and we've got like
two scientists looking breasts who for
some reason are whammer than a scientist
needs to be
okay they're just gym rats and glasses
basically yeah yeah yeah yeah okay and
you're strapped because you're like
subtly trying to see how tight yeah yeah
I'm like I'm looking yeah
and you're like this is impossible to
break I'm gonna die here all right say
let's I'm just I just want to analyze my
situation all right so that's the
situation all right so now you've got
pliers on your finger cool where is he
and this is playing on repeat and then
you keep seeing my face look straight at
the thing and you know they've got me
but this yeah
the thing is right I'll be I'll be
feeding the pressure of the pliers of my
finger and I'll be like why did we think
that myself why did you look at the
camera that's all I'll be thinking
because now I'm in this situation
because you looked at the camera yeah
wherever you live in I know but you also
were the ones tell me to run
yeah well I know as a boy so now where
is he Commander
crazy
he's also German yeah where is your
friend I'll be screaming I don't know I
don't know
I genuinely don't know where he is I was
screaming today I haven't whilst I'm
trying to like I will ask her once more
fair is he
so calm where is so calm so collected I
don't know I generally don't know stop
asking me get off my finger okay be like
Snap that's one we asked you twice you
didn't tell us where he was that thing
was gone yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're screaming you
can't actually believe what he just did
yeah I think I'll lose my voice box okay
I'll scream so loud I'll lose my voice
box won't be able to speak again and
I'll just pass out you'll pass out yeah
that's fine so they'll you'll pass out
the solder it to stop the bleeding so
they're burning your finger yeah yeah so
you're awake now I'm up now yeah yeah
and then you wake up and we've got the
finger number two where is he
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
out there they see I don't know swear
you don't know I don't know you're one
finger down you still don't know I need
water I need something I can't think
straight swear I can't think straight I
don't even know where I am I don't know
my name what's going on I'll be chatting
[ __ ] what's going on
is your good friend
you're a very good friend Hans Moore
where is he
where am I snap that's two yeah yeah
yeah yeah first of all you've been a
great friend so far you're down two
fingers and you're still saying I don't
even know where he is I don't know where
yeah bro I will I promise I'll be sorry
it's not even acting anymore I will be
disorientated all right cool from a
snapping the finger and like yeah yeah
burning it all right that's fine okay so
we've snapped the first finger yeah
you're disorientated and I believe you
yeah I'm saying all right bet so we
literally leave you to chill for like an
hour so I can come to yeah yeah you're
not disorientated anymore
we come back and all the pain subsides
so now you're adrenaline yeah that was
helping with the pain blocking all the
way down so now even just this is
hypersensitive you're shaking dripping
everything yeah good friend good friends
they see he's in a desert somewhere
there I I don't know which that it's a
vast desert big man it's a big thing I
don't know what stop stop I stop a blind
bro I've been looking at you saying stop
applying pressure
I can't breathe at the moment stop
applying pressure I can't breathe
there's no air there is he and now and
now yeah they they they click the remote
and it changes angles from my side of
the car to yours and it's you with your
phone and then point it like
there's a big red circle on maps and
you're like this one yeah
yeah you're pointing exactly where to go
I'm like if you saw that why are you
asking questions but we can't make it
out it's your business you have all this
technology yeah it's whose business your
business they swear snap that's two
fingers
uh to be fair
I would have I would pray to God I would
have died before that you haven't I
would have that I would have died
they've got I know myself I would have I
would have been long gone before them
long gone from a couple finger losses
them man I would I would make sure I
bleed out I don't know how but I'll make
sure I'd bleed out because I can't
I just can't deal with stuff like that
okay moral of the story is is you're not
willing to lose any more fingers no
you're not willing to tell them where I
am probably if if they go past two I
would I would try and lose my voice box
so I can't speak again all right fair
enough well let's say okay cool let's
say they do something where it's not
taking fingers let's do this nail thing
that you were talking about
painful yeah exactly
no bleeding out and they do it slowly
and they just start pulling up so they
strap your finger down yeah and then get
hooked satin under there and they just
start raising oh yeah that I might score
from the jump I'm not gonna lie I
probably would as well
I think a finger snip is so quick so
impactful and scream I'll be in pain but
I feel like the adrenaline might you
know oh the adrenaline wouldn't numb the
pain yeah and then once the thing is
gone you just quickly accept the fact
it's gone God there's nothing yeah and
if I've got one gone you might as well
take my hand it's gone yeah fingernail
yeah
that's dangerous yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll give you
coordinates right I'll give you
coordinates Rags bro yeah I'll take you
there
I'll tell you that so he knows it was me
yeah I'll pull up to the cave just like
that with half my finger bent up like
we'll have my nail half hanging off and
like I had no choice this is what they
did to me I literally had no choice I
think they might get one fingernail off
me I think this is well they wouldn't
even have to do a second one because if
I still wasn't willing to squeal they
could get like a toothbrush and threaten
to scrub the skin under the nail and
I'll tell him everything oh my God I can
look at Oral beating
no no no no no no I'll tell them
everything
I'll tell them literally everything
what made you even think of this
scenario I don't even know bro that's
why yeah so you reckon not even one
finger now you're you're telling them I
don't think so I think the fingernail
would traumatize me more than a finger
okay so let's say
you they apply pressure to the finger
now you say okay say less you give them
the coordinates and then
um would you feel regret because they
they go out get me half an hour I'm back
I'm screaming you hear me they walk
there's a there's a door to come into
the room yeah and then out of the room
yeah so they walk me in the room and I'm
like stop stop and I make eye contact
with you and you're strapped down and I
can see I can see there's no brothers no
nothing there's just a little thing near
your finger and I'm like wow makes sense
wow that's what it took
it
is
the threat of it I they leave me in
there long enough to just notice there's
no blood there's nothing and I say
you're not bleeding
why why fakes why you're not even
bleeding what would you say oh it took
[Music]
about you don't know what this feels
like you have no idea what this feels
like James I had to squeal say less I
had to say let's say let's say let's say
let's just try they just dragged me out
and they just torture me to death oh God
no how would you would you what'd you
tell my mom oh Jesus well that's all
your mom um I would say we got got
ourselves in a predicament I was
tortured he was tortured I survived so
yeah so when when you say I was tortured
she looks like up and down really and
she's concerned yeah what did they do I
didn't put a thing in my nail I'll tell
her to put a little thing in my nail I
was like
it was painful I don't think you get it
but it was painful I had to give him up
I had to it wasn't my first choice but
the fingernail thing is painful
sorry you obviously aren't coming to the
funeral but that's fine
that's obvious you're not allowed
allowed
I'd have to be there because the group
chat would also not let you oh because
because Jay would be in there saying I
wouldn't have a fingernail left
that's he'd be chatting them yeah
yeah he'd be in there like I wouldn't
have a feet a nailed to my name
they could take my toes too yeah take my
toes take all of it I would never say a
word
to the police yeah no not me
at least
yeah that's 100 and then remember like
yeah I'm not gonna lie still I don't
think I'd say nothing still and Toes
would just be toads will just send a gif
and leave it
is that a disappointed gift just shake
my head and just wow um the Idris Elba
one way he looks at two people shakes
his head and just walks back yeah yeah
well yeah oh my goodness what a scenario
yeah I would I would have to squeal bro
I'm sorry I would have to it is what it
is okay cool so you'd lose a finger for
me just not now
yeah as weird as that sounds yeah I
believe it yeah the nail thing is sounds
gruesome bro yeah yeah oh anyway
um I've got trash mix for you all right
but Florida man arrested after woman is
accidentally shot while twerking on him
oh my God the gun was the gun was on his
waist
a Florida man is now in custody after
being arrested on Tuesday for
accidentally shooting a woman that was
um while she was twerking when police
intervened so I went police interviewed
the victim on December 7th after um
being released from hospital she stated
that he um she had told the suspect 80
year old Marquis
um to stop playing with the gun
Witnesses say
um they saw her twerking on the stick
cell phone footage from the party and
actually showed adults and miners
dancing inside in the home hey drinking
alcohol
twist uh the victim the victim performed
to the police that she had been twerking
when she felt the firearm rub against
her firearm rubber gets the clap ass
why do they call it a club class
[Music]
[Laughter]
spot me
oh my God that spun me oh
um where am I
ah yeah the Victor confirmed that to the
police that she had been twerking when
she felt the firearm rubbing against her
clappers
the bullet entered her bullet entered
her back and left the front of her body
oh my literally talk about taking our
shots
the victim also showed investigators on
Instagram message and led you between
the guy on November 29th which read I am
truly sorry this was never intended to
happen especially to you if there's any
way I can get a second chance and talk
to you on the phone can you please let
me know and send me your number those
cheeks were too good he is currently
being held on 89 000 bond in jail
a second chance give me a second chance
this wasn't meantime it wasn't meant to
have you know it was an accident you
know it was an accident stop playing
with that gun oh
this
is
it's time to be dance for me don't Don't
Dance
how about armed weapons
this is one of two yeah come on don't
dance for man clappers need to clap dots
for man I know
through and through no no there's no way
because she would look down and see it
if I was her I promise you I'll come out
I could never just hear a noise and look
down and see
no no no no no I'll collapse drop to
your knees I will collapse wow that is
that's obviously
America to it like you just done stuff
like that is just Madness to me yeah
it's impossible why are you whining on a
breader when he's got a gun on his waist
like as soon as you feel it get up leave
the building move that whatever this is
in the yard as well it's not even a
strip club or nothing it's a yard
miners are in there too that drinking
alcohol and dancing West yeah the whole
thing was Wild West I couldn't believe
that when I read that jeez yeah I
couldn't believe that when I read that
much that's all nuts all nuts right so
that could be that situation you've got
a dilemma for us as well right I do have
it done for you guys cool okay ready yep
hi guys big fan of the show I've been
watching it yada yada yada
um Love by the way obviously
um I got a five-year relationship three
months ago I've worked to myself and a
lot and I've worked on myself a lot in
the past year and a half losing 70
pounds changing a lifestyle mental
health Etc
I'm feeling good about myself also I've
been getting a lot of male attention
okay
very gang however I am trying to get
back out there never been on a dating
app or anything and I feel like I'm
lacking so much confidence
I still haven't picked um I still
haven't picked a bio yet because I'm
overthinking everything even the sexual
confidence with girls I think a lot of
guys want a low body count now I don't
really care about um or that I don't
really care about that BS but I feel
like I feel a lot embarrassed as a 23
year old as I've only been with one
person who was Vanilla in Brackets you
put I know I've not had a lot of
experience but still
I'm scared that I won't be good in bed
talking about sex and all of that stuff
makes me feel intimidated sorry for the
novel but I'm wondering if you had any
advice to how to gain some confidence
so long story short
um she was in a five-year relationship
she only got out of it three years three
months ago
um she worked on herself lost 70 pounds
changed her lifestyle changed her mental
health now she's getting bag of
attention she's never been on any dating
apps whatsoever she lacks a lot of lots
of confidence and doesn't really like
like to engage in sexual chat she
doesn't even know what to put in her bio
she's 23 years old only been with one
brother her whole life
and now she's just thinking how do I
even initiate sex period with anyone I
need help I need confidence what do I do
um
to be fair this is uh I can definitely
understand why she feels that way I
would definitely feel that way as well
however is
hmm
there's nothing that I do now
that I didn't fantasize doing when I was
like 21. do you know what I mean and
like it's not like
stuff that I learned along the way
it's all stuff that I knew about and
just now actively feel more comfortable
just doing it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
just doing it yeah but even still till
now if I was to sleep with someone brand
new tomorrow I'm not going in there all
guns blazing yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
a formality to it of course of course
yeah you have to get comfortable even
with someone that you see me if you
don't just unless you've been talking up
the most beforehand yeah you don't just
jump straight into the deep end you just
do the normal vanilla stuff and then see
how it goes it escalates from there so
yeah she I don't think she needs to
worry about that at all just go in with
the toolbox that she's learned so far
and being with someone five years
regardless if it's the same person you
know enough you do you know enough to
get in the ballpark and then yeah
literally it's just going to be vanilla
moving forward if anything you should be
worried if you're meeting a guy and you
just have a nice chat you sleep in the
first time and he goes yeah yeah yeah he
don't care if you like it or not he just
goes huh
nah bro that's concerning yeah that is
very concerning so don't worry about all
that
yeah I would just go in there with your
toolbox and see why I go on and then
stuff that you imagine that you like or
whatever eventually you're just you'll
talk about it with the breath that
you're consistently sleeping with and
then
just go from there I guess that's good
that's good advice I feel like
um considering she said she was with her
brother for five years
um and he he was Vanilla I would think
if I was in her shoes I'd be like what
are the things that I would want I would
have wanted him to do to me during this
five-year span that he didn't do you
know if you're if you're saying he's
quote unquote vanilla what more could
some bring to your table to make you
feel like maybe I want this or maybe I
want that or maybe I should try this so
so he can initiate that so I don't feel
like you don't even need necessarily
need to go on uh dating apps or anything
like that because
people orchestrate that in different
ways and sometimes it's a hit sometimes
it's a Miss but I feel like
an organic conversation you can kind of
spark you can't you can kind of gauge
what that person is and how they may be
sexually by a regular conversation yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so you can just
just keep talking or just find someone
you can have a normal conversation with
that you you may be attracted to have a
normal conversation with feel
comfortable with
and then you never know that that
vanilla aspect might just disperse
because you're going to feel comfortable
around that yeah yeah rags and like the
fact that she even knows that homeboy
was Vanilla that means that she yeah
mine's already on stuff
in some field yeah yeah so it's calm
it's like yeah just just go in say what
you're comfortable with and like there's
there's really not as much I can imagine
feeding like there's a lot like behind
this door yeah everyone's in on this
thing and I don't know about it yeah I'm
not previously it's not yeah it's not
even the case it's genuinely not even
the case you just yeah you learn on the
job because and everyone's different yes
I was gonna say literally sex is
different for everyone like I think
before we even started this pod or
whilst whilst we're um in the process of
doing this pod we had an episode I'm
sure we talked about
that sex for us is like different from
sex with other people do you know what I
mean like yeah yeah there's the
different doors in Sex and it's like
I've we've run out some things and um in
the past and it just made me feel like
oh these men are having sex yeah I'm
vanilla yeah yeah
you know what I mean yeah yeah I'm just
doing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
times where I think oh I'm wrong yeah
yeah I'm up there I thought yeah about
myself and then I hear something I'm
like swear yeah this is a performance
yeah you know Jesus so everyone is
vanilla to someone so don't make that
make you feel bad you know so just just
just just believe in your juice and like
you said you've got um a lot more mental
confidence you look better you feel
better so you and you're getting a lot
more male attraction
own that use that to your
um what's the word I'm looking for use
that to your
um not ability
um but just right right that way
basically yeah just ride that wave it's
true and everyone's that's another thing
as well everyone's vanillas
yeah everyone's vanilla is different
yeah so for example like
I like a certain thing so if uh if a
thing if I'm sleeping with a girl and
she says spit in my mouth calm yeah
right that's vanilla to me yes level one
yeah yeah right and I'm down because
that's level one yeah I'm not thinking
oh I'm thinking it's Wednesday yeah yeah
it turns out it's Wednesday now we're
going but then if a thing
said lick my foot bottom I'll be a bit
like oh okay you're a bit you're a bit
Advanced you're here but she might be
thinking that's vanilla but to me
because I'm not really into that I'm a
bit like oh okay
we're in the deep end are we yeah yeah
yeah we're looking crusty foot yeah yeah
so I'm just looking to you now yeah yeah
I'm bazooka and verucas today to say
less
yeah yeah okay cool but yeah to her
she's more like that's really basic that
is basically and I might turn to
tingling I'm trying to spit that mouth I
should be like Jesus Christ brother I've
been in that's not not in that situation
but I've had
um conversations with not many women but
a few women in the past
um just about like
what their sexuality is like in terms of
like their sex and stuff and I've said
Australian math is calm this is calmness
calm and exactly you said spit in the
mouth and she was like
yeah
I'm thinking whoa yeah that's yeah that
Stage 1.5 that's not even a stage it's a
man do you know what I mean that's light
yeah I could spell you just because I'm
lips in you bruh on your face and I
still think this is life bro like what
are we discussing what are we actually
discussing how have you not been spotted
yeah yeah this is the game how you've
not been smart yeah this is so light so
yeah stuff like that baffles me yeah
yeah yeah so I can understand where
you're coming from in terms of like the
vanilla aspect and like the lack of
confidence and you don't know how to
like process or maneuver the the sexual
conversation stuff like that but
everyone's vanilla is different
believing your juice believing your
squeeze like you said you've lost weight
you look good you feel good mentally
um and yeah the man damage is all over
you apparently so ride that wave here
and you will scoop sign yeah catch some
bodies and it's like yeah man don't talk
about your Galley and the man them will
Frolic yeah and this I'm worrying about
like oh guys don't like a high body
count I was like first of all if you're
dealing with real men they're never
gonna know what your body count is
anyway so it literally doesn't I'm never
gonna ask yeah so any man that's asking
about your body count you don't need me
to be sleeping yeah yeah that's trust me
any guy that asks your body count
shouldn't add to that body count factual
there you go sign still delivered all
right okay anyway guys thank you so much
for today this is a good one
um good length on this one I think as
well as always guys head on over to
patreon.com catch us on Thursday
um and yeah love love
[Music]